where are you from are you from Boston
uh originally from Guangzhou China China
okay China good country good country
good
[Music]
we have to say that now correct oh the
phone listening oh the phone listening
his nephew got Huawei phone they all
listening
you use expressvpn
[Applause]
oh government hear that please
oh our phone tap into it Long Live
presidency Long Live presidency
oh
Uncle Roger social credit score going up
nice
from China okay anyone anyone and he's a
nephew from Taiwan
[Applause]
not a real country not a real
not a real country
I hope one day you rejoined the
motherland One China
no no don't clap too hot there's no
political show
Uncle Rich are going to get canceled
after tonight
I basically um
kind of kind of marked both sides you
know I think that's a good comic you
need to play both sides and get both
sides pissed off at you otherwise it
feels you feel more like a politician if
you just very Pro or leaning against one
side right so in that bit I made I think
I I pulled off making fun of both uh
China and and Taiwan at the same time
and again these are all jokes you know I
come to my show there's maybe like just
just that joke kind of touches on a
political nerve somewhat lightly but the
things I say is like oh Huawei are they
all listening that's kind of things we
all say right yeah oh Chinese oh they're
all listening oh anyone from Taiwan or
not a real country not a real country
that's kind of jokes that's like the
standard in a comedy club you find out
where someone's from you make fun of
their country yeah move on to the next
person that's what you do it's not even
that big a deal it's just no maybe I I
know more about this because of my
cancellation so I I could like I was
quick and off the coffin and a little
bit of a spoiler here I've done the joke
many times you know it looks like this
you know improvise oh you're from China
no a lot of my shows I have people from
China coming to my shows and
um I have to say I still like close to
100 000 tickets for the tour that bit
worked everywhere you know uh I I did
have to cancel Taiwan but that wasn't
because of the bit that was because the
code covet restrictions were still there
uh so it worked everywhere I know it's a
good bit I know it's uh it's funny and I
know it also will ruffle some feathers
it's a little bit slightly controversial
and it's just fun
so I know that was gonna do well I
didn't know I was gonna do this well
yeah appearing on BBC and everything so
I posted that and then
um uh again the same thing happened
somebody I didn't post it on Chinese
socials because yeah on Chinese socials
you can't really mention the president
by name that is just a No-No and
why go through the trouble I have a
feeling they're gonna be pissed off at
this and I was right but I didn't post
it on any Chinese socials somebody again
some nationalists way more person
screenshotted that and then posted it on
their accounts and then my account got
reported and suspended this time so now
even though you didn't post it I didn't
post it so they haven't banned you for
breaking the rules of weibo they've
banned you for having the what they
think is the wrong opinion even though
it's just a joke essentially initially I
got banned because of the reports from
other people but my Chinese social media
team my current one has recently
informed me that band also is not just a
social media platform but it also came
from higher up but whatever that means I
don't know what that means what I know
is I probably won't be able to go to
China or Hong Kong in the uh in
indefinite future which is you know it's
the price I have to pay I can still go
to Taiwan hopefully before China like
nukes them I should go before I can see
why you got canceled
so so you you have that video we'll
we'll include it in this if yeah it's
okay uh and then your Chinese social
media accounts get nuked anything else
uh I'm I think all four of them got nuke
right yeah I'm like four four Chinese
socialists now so and then
I I I've learned from last time I know I
know if I make any sort of statement
trying to like say oh on Chinese social
just saying that oh it's just a joke
guys and by the way the Chinese fans on
my socials and they all know it's just a
joke it's like they all they all enjoy
it it's just this very tiny it's kind of
like the Western World too right the
social justice jingoistic Warriors
they're like oh I can't believe he
humiliated China this there's a term in
in Mandarin currently it's a very trendy
term called ruhua and it translates to
humiliate China and then uh there's a
joke in the Taiwanese like and the
anti-china country circles that go like
uh uh humiliating China is the thing
everybody goes through because they are
so sensitive that kind of thing so there
are three things in in life that you
will do you were born you humiliate
China and you die
so and and I just learned about all of
this and it is true there's a very vocal
very sensitive people who who will
report everything uh and coincidentally
when I was canceled the day before there
was a Chinese comedian his name is Lee
Hauser he made a joke I listened to that
joke he just said oh I saw some a few
dogs and they were like she was really
really energetic and I really want him
to protect my house because those dogs
reminded me of and he said the Chinese
military catchphrase uh I forgot to
catch him but he basically used that
catchphrase in that bit and the Bitcoin
and Applause break I listened to that
actual bit so everybody in the comedy
club found it funny but apparently
somebody recorded illegal footage of
just audio posted it he he might face
three months in jail he he his
management company is fine 1.5 million
uh pounds wow yeah so it is fortunate
that you know I'm not my nationality is
not Chinese you know my ethnicity yes
you know Chinese but that that that's
always tricky Isn't it nice to be white
sometimes you know what I mean
foreign